alors moi j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
d'interviews
yvan attal vous disiez toujours oui mais
alors vous ne couperez pas refaire une
interview oui mais alors je vous demande
simplement de cuire la pâte
j'adore ce film et mais je l'adorent un
point tu peux même pas imaginer
je suis peut-être pas le meilleur
réalisateur du monde mais mais au moins
dans mon film j'ai les meilleurs acteurs
du monde
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais d'autres non plus d'ailleurs
vous avez quoi l'oreille là je suis né
comme ça
ah bon je crois que c'était je vous dis
la vérité je vous aviez une boucle
d'oreille quelqu'un vous l'avez je suis
très en forme je raconte tout un baratin
comme quoi je serais une femme et qu'on
a mais là je suis né comme ça ce soir la
vérité pas vous faire chier jeu plaît
beaucoup aux femmes
mais où est le problème c'est vrai je
veux beaucoup mais je suis marié je suis
une star chez les gays mais mais je
n'apprécie pas spécialement les
partouzes mai mais c'est parce que je
suis très jaloux l'un dans l'autre
j'aime pas et sandwichs grecs mais dans
une partouze
je suis pour la paix dans le monde mais
c'est pas gagné
bien à temps voilà c'est vrai je dois
jouer mais j'ai toujours j'ai peur de
mourir mais ça je me soigne j'ai envie
de vous tirer même mais un peu trop de
monde et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux